impossible de la rater la poule de woods
en est omniprésente au numéro 3 le
restaurant de laurent et julie prochain
en salles mais aussi dans son jardin
voit bien le sont pas sauvages ils ont
l'habitude de raisons l'habitude de nous
voir et si c'est vraiment pour pour
montrer à nos clients ce qu'est
exactement la poule de houdan lorsque
tout le monde n'est pas des yvelines
dont tout le monde ne connaît pas la
poule 2 août un peu lâche caillou thé
blanc et noir avec une petite houpette
la volaille de houdan a connu son heure
de gloire au 20e siècle
aujourd'hui elle a disparu de nos
assiettes on assiste décidé avec eric
sanso qui est éleveur à auffargis de
relancer le la production de la poule 2
ou dans deux fois trois fois dans
l'année parce qu'il ya aussi six mois de
production six mois d'élevage et pour la
retrouver sur nos tables quoi on va
dresser un travail autour de l'offre
autour de la fin là où on va travailler
l'oeuf mayonnaise savent que la
mayonnaise avait travaillé avec des
truffes on va travailler blanc d'oeuf et
un titeuf
on va rajouter un titeuf de kayes
pauchet installé depuis douze ans ou
tremblay sur mauldre laurent et une
étoile depuis onze ans c'est donc en
toute logique que le chef travail des
plats autour de la poule et de l'oeuf et
publie un ouvrage de recettes en 2015 le
but de ce livre c'est évidemment de
montrer notre maison de montrer notre
cuisine de montrer la poule de montrer
ce cette aventure humaine mais c'est
aussi de dire que voilà avec la volaille
on peut cuisiner et on est quand même
aujourd'hui dans des cuisines aussi à la
maison plus simple recherchée mais tout
en gardant aussi un certain budget le
livre propose entre et amuse-bouche plat
et dessert
laurent trochain partage également
quelques astuces de chef pour que la
volaille n'ai plus aucun secret